ein montiertes corona virus macht den
dänen dort angst die regierung in
kopenhagen hat die notschlachtung aller
nerze im land angekündigt zuvor war bei
einigen tieren eine mutierte form des
virus gefunden worden
auch bei zwölf menschen wurde diese
neuartige form dann nachgewiesen zur
vermeidung einer weiteren ausbreitung
einer mutierten form des neuartigen
corona virus sind im nordwesten
dänemarks scharfe sicherheitsmaßnahmen
angeordnet worden
betroffen sind demnach mehr als 280.000
menschen mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren